l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo sul video
che stava aspettando anche gesù ma per
fortuna sono cristiano perché se mi
cristiano non fossi questo video
potrebbe avere ripercussioni contro gesù
per chi a ragazzi di cosa si tratta non
lo sapete già perché l'avete già letto
dal titolo furbacchioni quando mi sono
messo il gesto ragazzi ho chiesto come
già difficile giocare col gesto
qualsiasi videogame consigliate vedevano
da giocare che sia ancora più difficile
da fare con il gesto ovviamente che
videogame mi avete consigliato se non il
grandissimo è incredibile [ __ ]
bastardo di merda che ti deve morire il
fratello di trombosi acuta le narici
nasali comunqe ragazzi sto per giocare a
chieti mario col gesso grazie di
avermelo consigliato a qua c'è scritto
che sono stupido e qua c'è scritto che
sono scemo devo scegliere tra le due la
prima grazie zio allora ex come si muove
con i tasti direzionali solo la sinistra
e ragazzi non uso nient'altro che la
sinistra sarà difficile ragazzi questo
non lo nego però ci si prova
ok con molta calma abbiamo appena
cominciato ragazzini tranquilli che c'è
possibilità stai facendo
parlando e fai pazzo va bene è caro
ascoltami
se non vuoi che ti ingessi la faccia no
sa già che c'è il cubo ok afa bosso
posto merda si no tutti calmi calmi
tutti prima che gli spacchi l'altra mano
a parte il fatto che la sinistra e
quindi con la sinistra già difficile di
suo pc oppure gesso
[Musica]
porca eva si si io l'ansia perfetto
perfetto non faccio schifo ma ho parlato
ingessate mila box è perfetto
ragazzi se misfatto no no se ti spacco
la mamma non devo morire per forza che
non mi ricordavo si morisse con le
nuvole di mortacci sua
si no ma sono molto prima mi chiedo
prova quale sarà già un simulator col
gesso impossibile ma fan cuore il tuo
gatto amavisca ass
e tu ami il tuo gatto io non so perché
il mio gatto li farei passare un tir
sulla faccia rango no zio notte vi
salvate di saltare come tua madre in
autostrada devi saltare bravo non mi
ricordo cosa devo fare non sbagliato
morto
sono morto son deficienza non deficiente
lo so ricordando all'alzheimer ragazzi
d'alzheimer ma perché contro tutti i
giochi che ho fatto nella mia vita credo
che che mario alla lunga si sa ancora il
peggiore sarge un simulator mi ha fatto
chris tornare abbastanza bucket mario
cali mortacci mi sa ke kazzo successo
con i commenti nelle persone che figo
cool kids gr the best game ivers in sé
beccato vado a gli faccio il cervello
mente cap cioè mente che il segnale si
sapeva già era che non c'era bisogno di
leggerne come no no no no chiedevi
entrare nel buco che non lo centrale
anche tuo padre il buco sì sì
cioè no no no non ho usato la sinistra a
sinistra giura ok
sì sì porca vacca lytham anni ci ho
messo perché ci sono topolino e quindi
de foucauld se successo i ragazzi a
grazie che starebbe a significare bravo
che hai vinto livello col gesso quando
in realtà c'è scritto che mi puzzavano
però vabbè pensavo di aver finito non ha
già a livello 2 meno 16 grazie ad un
dati sotto i soldi già fatta sono morto
non sei molto ce l'ho fatta che botta di
culo raga non mi ricordavo è andata di
culo
infatti non mi dico io non mi ricordo
niente di chè 0
al ragazzo è tristissimo pensare che il
primo video che ho fatto di cat mario
non ero arrivato fino qua eos è usato
entrambe le mani quindi un pochettino
sono migliorato nel contempo purtroppo
super sayan non mi ricordo più raga non
mi ricordo più seychelles tua madre dai
tubi non lo so non me lo ricordo bene
ecco perfetto come si fa a passare che
il gioco simpatico non ha voglia di
vivere pensando di gioco di me va beh
dove vado io doveva al vado a [ __ ]
vanno a [ __ ] feto si no eh vabbè
quanti cod che siede una famiglia ma
serio
no fermi ragazzi cos'è sta ma no a
liberarmi prenderà per il culo mi
prenderà per il culo strano non era
ancora capitato il suo gioco che mi
prende solo per il culo credo di aver
capito crea che ok non ho capito non ho
proprio non mi ricordo che come ho fatto
uno cener ce n'era uno si sono
moltiplicati per adesso non so come
vincere non so come farà in un idea
[Musica]
666 sì qualcuno mi gesti l'altra ma sto
spaccato il posto mi piace ansia non ci
posso credere sa è assurdo grande come
se festa per il non mi torna anche più è
giusto è giusto ce l'ho fatta lo ha già
mi fossi anche questa ma forse non era
la stella ragazzi devo prendere quel
prof c'era un fungo tipo una volta
eccolo cade il fungo il tizio cade giù
ce l'ha fatta
no ragazzi non avete questa parte qua è
impossibile non so come ho fatto
l'impossibile sì sì sì
oddio oddio no no non ci credo non ci
credo non è bus
ero alla fine però la fico mi sono morto
un deficiente la parte più facile
[Musica]
ok
non ci credo mai non ci credo ma il
ragazzo è stato è stato impossibile ve
lo dico però dire che ci siamo figo
grazie delle stelle o anche mi sembrava
strano bravo bravo ok devo saltare su
quello dopo questo perfetto se questo no
no scusa a livello qua ragazzi non me lo
zero non mi ricordo niente quindi vado a
caso completamente
si ok cosa incredibile ragazzi cosa
incredibile cosa incredibile
vabbè amica quello che mi lanciava vermi
sono i boscolo vivo oddio sto male 9 è a
tal switch suicidi the suicidi che va
giù bravo fratello grave non mi ricordo
le cose per culo a st barth equa ecco
non sta parte quando non ce la farò mai
più o meno vita ce l'ho fatta una volta
per culo no è impossibile questa è
veramente impossibile
[Musica]
stacchiamo ragazzi ho dato prova di
grande coraggio di grande formaggio con
in giocando mario col gesso e sono anche
riuscito per l'amor di dio a fare tre
livelli non 13 comunque ragazzi quello
che episodio spero che vide un sia per
cento spero siate contenti allora in
realtà ha fatto questo episodio perché
domani mi tolgono in teoria gesto quindi
non potrò più fare questa cosa l'ho
aspettato l'ultimo giorno per farlo
perché volevo che questa agonia non
arrivasse mai però è arrivata comunque
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto spero
che il gesto vi sia piaciuto perché
finalmente domani melo le volar cazzo
spero mi sia piaciuto è consentito video
è piaciuto al suo momento è un mi piace
anche a pacciani facebook e con il 80
notizia non so se non si fischia tesi
vediamo prossimo video senza gesto
possibilmente belle ragazze